اذا كان رصيد ترامب الشعبي الا يضمن فوزه
برئاسه ثانيه فماذا عن بعضا رئيسا شعبيته
تتهاوى وبالارقام الى تسعه الممثلتين في
المئه بحسه باخر استطلاع عنا اجرته وكاله
رويترز مع ابسوس ارضيه متعثره لترشحه
لولايه ثانيه لكن الرئيس لا يملك الخيار
الكلمه للحزب وعدم ترشحه سيفقده واحس به
اهتمام الاعلام والكونغرس والجمهور الا
اذا تحول التركيز على مرشح جديد وبالعرف
السياسي سيصبح بيضا بطه عرسها اذا تخلى عن
سباق 200424
التوضيح المصطلح يشير الى فتره ان التعاقب
انتخابات التسديد النصفي وغالبا ما يعجز
فيها الرئيس عن فعلي اي شيء عن تشريعيه
كونه يفقده اغلبيه احد المجلستين على
الاقل وهي حقيقه ادركها رؤساء امريكا منذ
العام 19 او 86
ويدركوا خطورتها المحيطين المحيطون ببيضه
اليوم التخلي عن الترشح قد يعني اعترافا
ضمينيا بالفشل وفقدان القدره على المنافسه
ومواكبه الخصم وحتى الان لم يقدم بيضا
اعلانه الرسمي
ولما حالي ذلك
لرئاسه الحزب الديمقراطي حاكمته مثلا
شعبيتها اعلنت انها لن تنافس على الرئاسه
تاجيل الاعلامي في هذه الحاله لا يكون
لسبب واحد والعهده على مايكل افيبر استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه تكساس
لا يريد ان يشتت وسائل الاعلام عن اداراته
والاجنده التي يعمل بتحقيقها خاصه تلك
التي يتطلب تمريرها عبر الكونجرس